der agb mein name ist sie ja wer hätte
gedacht mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video film school in meinem zimmer ohne
job
also dass menschen es gibt noch nicht im
luca müther per 6
und ja ihr seid ja auch hier wegen dem
video ein video im internet gefunden
erkennst du diese youtuber als kinder
und da habe ich mir gedacht klar hier
klicken einfach mal auf play denen
eingeblendet erkennst du diese youtuber
als kinder also wieder so ein youtube
wird doch wieder an den union au wieder
hayes oder grüß dich genau hat wird auch
die letzten gemacht
und das hier ist der erbguts über den
wir erwarten ich mach mal wieder auf
stop zwischendurch weil diese 23
sekunden das ist ein bisschen zu kurz
finde ich nicht erinnert mich an gegen
ihn aber überhaupt nichts sagen gerade
ich finde es enorm schwierig gerade bei
solchen kinderbildern ich selber hätte
mich zum beispiel auch nicht auf meine
kinder bildern erkannt tag einfach mal
das radio nicht bin mir nicht sicher
aber ich will ein bisschen ähnlich also
1 und wir haben als youtube ein bully
im moment wartet mal
da wäre ich im leben nicht drauf
gekommen es war auf jeden fall ein blatt
lösungen das nächste youtube
ich würde sagen julia weiß nicht ob es
ein mädchen oder ein junge ist das ist
sehr sehr schwierig hier also ich glaube
wir sind uns alle einig dass es ein
asiate und ich oder schenkt
ja
eskortiert runter drei freie und numero
eins und jetzt wie mir die ausbildung
meine damen und herren zwar ist es ist
schon im bett
ich wollte mehr sagen was eine kacke
mann ich habe mit der zeit von weiteren
falsch ich habe geerbt das sage ich auch
noch zehn meter youtuber haben wir hier
eingeblendet dass bin da vielleicht ich
[Gelächter]
genau so war ich doch ich bin mir
überhaupt nicht wie ich würde sagen dass
ich das bin ich einfach mal weiter auf
play gewinnt und noch eine betont haben
dass zeit und gleich nochmal die
auflösung nebeneinander eheleute das
hätte auch wirklich tätig sein können
aber weiter mit ihm in kontakt ist ja so
klar
auch wieder ich hatte sascha von den
aussenseitern als wenn ich an dieser
stelle direkt auf video meine damen und
herren was davon aus so weiter dann mit
ihr gewesen
ein erster punkt beim vierten youtuber
hier nochmal die auflösung der beiden
bilder nebeneinander hat sich bin ich
fast gar nicht verändert mir lieber da
kann ich auch direkt weiter machen ja
hier wieder die auflösung nebeneinander
und dann machen wir direkt meister mit
dem nächsten youtube hier melina sophie
alter ich muss gar nicht mehr stoppen
bevor
hier nochmal die gegenüberstellungen bin
ich plötzlich auch natürlich von den han
und comic style herbert verändert okay
die sicht kommt mir irgendwie bekannt
vor
also ich bin gerade bei video punkten
aber ich mache jetzt einfach ein ort mit
dem beide haben mir fällt in deutschland
genau der name einer fusion 4,69 punkte
okay ich würde sagen dafür dass ich
gesagt habe dass seine band hole ich mir
einen punkt also bin ich jetzt bei acht
punkten hier nochmal die
gegenüberstellung ja es stimmt schon
dass der ähnlichkeiten davon gesicht
hervor
da geb ich sag einfach sagen wie also
will ich jetzt nicht sein
ich glaube die wagen ist dem pummeliger
früher und melina hatten wir gerade in
essen
jedoch mal die gegenüberstellung ich bin
immer noch bei acht punkten meine damen
und herren mit dem nächsten youtuber
hier damit definitiv gebiet palace das
ist 100 prozent meine damen und herren
haltet euch fest auflösung und die
virtuelle morgens ok alles gar
akzeptiere ich hier nochmal die
gegenüberstellung ich bin bei neun
punkten
das heißt machen direkt weiter mit dem
nächste youtube basterds
ich bin youtube fortgeschritten
brand
ja
ich habe mir so die hände aneinander
geschlagen das was richtig wehgetan hat
das video meine damen und herren wir
durch gefeiert würde ich mich berger
unlike freundin findet jetzt hier ein
pfeil die eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
könnte meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren
augen findet ihr auch meinen shop
eingeblendet wie schon beim ersten
sechsten stock unter anderem dieses t
shirt sehr sehr gute qualität superspion
ist ein anderes video
cloud